[Music]
once upon a time the end of the passage here
we work once upon a time we do
n't need an account it's for
children
that's good we are children
who are the biggest there is no question
that  this individual and escape my
anger little heroes but how far you want
no I came to save you where is he
me I know of course sir I know
everything so who is who rico you
can't imagine everything that  he was able to
accomplish in let's see we were able to see
everything that this rise touches am too
small to tell us what to do
generosity dragons play we no way
he's listening you inherited
your father's tones be very careful we don't
can disobey kahrama witches
you of course glory
I am lost
from his victory on his bench it was nice
shot is not dense but he
on costs and men and
women but especially kirikou for
him alone in fact he is  happy in the
rain and the wind
he lives intensely